en lisant l'article ça m'a choqué parce
qu'il ya des détails qui me concerne
dalila matoub enseigne la maternelle
depuis 12 ans dans le quartier rosemont
à montréal
elles portent le hidjab et peut
continuer d'enseigner avec son voile
malgré la loi sur la laïcité c'est son
droit acquis apple a réalisé que le père
d'une élève ne voulait pas que
l'enseignant sa fille elle a été
ébranlée
j'avais la trouille dans mon ventre elle
c'est la première fois que je vis un
stress un stress gratuit pourquoi je
vais méritée face la direction de
l'école a rejeté la requête du père le
ministère aussi la loi ne donne pas de
nouveaux droits relatifs à la question
religieuse la loi est plus là pour les
nouveaux enseignants qui ne porteront
pas que sa mort est julien lepers de
heureusement n'est pas le seul à s'être
invitée dans le débat
dans une lettre ouverte d'autres parents
a pu comme lui la laïcité mais rejette
le principe du droit à qui il souhaite
être entendu par le ministre robert
chaque parent on a droit à des services
publics
notre et laïque et quant à 6 on signaux
qui ne sont pas soit disant laïque
je pense qu'ils doivent stationner je ne
suis pas contre qui l'ont scène il doit
y avoir peut-être des gens qui
aimeraient avoir leurs enfants avec ses
enseignants là mais qui nous donne le
choix à nous de choisir ses enseignants
de la commission scolaire de montréal se
pose depuis le début à la loi il était
persuadé d'ailleurs que de telles
situations allait se produire à la
rentrée j'ai des collègues qui m'ont dit
tout l'été le qui est supposé d'être un
moment de repos un moment de vacances un
moment de plaisir avec la famille il ya
eu de gros stress parce que ça demandait
est ce que je veux être la personne à
qui ça va m'arriver
est-ce que je vais avoir un contrecoup
d'un parent qui va dire non moi je
l'avais pas je le veux c'est je veux
qu'elle enlève son flanc le ministre
reste clair
moi j'invite tout le monde à appliquer
la loi mais pas à la dépense et puis
aller plus loin et sa position est
saluée par la centrale des syndicats du
québec
jusqu'où va sept ans les demandes pour
dia par des parents l'ont alors je pense
que la démocratie s'est exercée en
commission parlementaire
mais ses parents qui évoque la liberté
de conscience pour est il demandé aux
tribunaux de leur permettre de changer
leurs enfants de classe si l'enseignant
porte un signe religieux pour une
professeur qui est déjà en place qui
exerçait ses fonctions au moment de la
mise en vigueur de la loi 21
cette personne-là et protégé dans la loi
l'y rien dans la loi qui dit précisément
que parent pourrait retirer un enfant
d'un classe cl
le prof affiche un signe religieux
françois legault a souvent dit que la
nouvelle loi allait clore un débat qui
durait depuis près de 15 ans en cette
rentrée scolaire le débat semble plutôt
relancé de plus belle et de nouvelles
questions surgissent ici catherine
gauthier radio canada montréal